we got road dates coming up not together
separately
but you know look you're g
hopefully they're on separate weekends
and you can see both of us
and if we're on the same weekend in your
town you're gonna have to make a choice
i don't know what to tell you
but i'll be at helium
comedy club in buffalo uh january 27th
28th 29th i'm gonna be at bananas in new
jersey
uh the fourth and fifth of february i'm
gonna be at the punch line in
philadelphia
march 10th 11th and 12th and i'm going
to be
at
uh in austin texas at the creek and cave
uh the 20th and 21st of may and there's
some other dates and things that are
popping up that i'm not allowed to
announce yet but will be coming soon
to a city near you what's up guys just
going to give you some tour dates here
uh i will be in des moines um
indianapolis and cleveland this coming
weekend friday saturday and sunday the
14th 15th and 16th uh over in california
uh in san diego on the 21st and in los
angeles on the 22nd
uh after that we are moving to
burlington
uh and foxwoods at the end of the month
january 28th and 29th and then detroit
on february 11th pittsburgh on february
12th we added second shows to both of
those and then the egg in albany on
february 18th second show ended there uh
capital one hall in tysons virginia on
the 19th of february and then february
26th i'm in madison and february 27th i
am at the vic we have also added second
shows there you can get all tickets at
savile kennel comedy.com come on out
oh i forgot to say my website i'm a
idiot
leave this part in
i was parted oh i thought he was going
to chop these up anyway i don't think
we're going to oh i thought we were
going together um joe derosa
what is it joe derosa info
why is it jordan rosen
it used to be joe derosa comedy and then
i got a new
i don't know guys just come see me i'm
in a bad way you know
you can hear it i can't i can't remember
my website name
uh i'll see you out there
jodarossainfo.com for all tickets uh
links and show info and all that good
stuff will be there
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hidey ho taste buddies it is the taste
buds podcast i am sal volcano and with
me today we have none other than the one
and only
ryan quinn brian quinn is back with us
yes i have been enjoying this i don't
want again i don't want joe to feel bad
or anything no i know i know you and i
used to host a podcast called what say
you
uh it we started it and i guess 2012 or
13. yeah
and i'm actually looking at the award we
we got right there and that crazy we
came out swinging we came out there's an
award i have on my
shelf here
2013 stitcher award for best new podcast
yeah let's say you yeah and uh we loved
it we had uh our fans are called the
nuggalos yes um because of a demonic
honey bear that was the nugget yeah
he's the demonic honey bear that was
that basically became the mascot of the
show yeah and i think we mentioned it
last time we used to go on field trips
it was just it was good
we stopped down we only did about a
year's worth of episodes maybe a little
more than that maybe 70. i don't know
what it was we did a bunch 72 yeah
something like that anyway but it's been
defunct
we we we pepper them in once in a while
but
we keep talking this is we keep talking
about it and this is really
this has really been fun because you
haven't done this in so long it's good
well it's just like it's fun because
like there's very few people in the
world that i have i mean you and i have
worked so closely together for so many
years and you're my best friend so it's
like
you it's like 30 years of really like
i'm not really closer to many more
people than you you know what i mean
yeah so it's like it's just fun to get
to like it just doesn't even feel like
anything yeah like it's like blast yeah
it is car because how often do you also
sit down with a friend and then just
carve out time for straight talking with
no interference you don't really do that
you know even if you're a bar or you had
a you're at a house or you're whatever
it's usually not just like chopping it
up straight so this is fun though it's
like i come over here we like we chill
out we i know i have you on the bat
phone
you know
something goes down with the rose and he
can't do it i'm like can you make it and
he's like yeah this is great what's that
line from uh uh from a wedding singer
where he's like derose is losing his
mind
all the benefits
he was so funny in that john uh
lovitz yeah yeah when he's like shotgun
oh god where did he go he had that
comedy club in la for a while and then i
haven't seen her
how was he not
a comedy legend i i would say that in in
circles he's you know he's
he's old guard he's a i don't i don't
see him around much i don't know how
much he does now like actually getting
up and
if he's working on this act but i i
would say
well he is a comedy legend yeah he is
yeah i i i i misphrase that but i was
like remember how much before he died we
saw robin williams everywhere i thought
you were just going to say
like when you said remember though
before he died i was like john no no no
no no but like i feel he should be on
like the level with like uh yeah with
like uh
yeah i don't know about robin williams i
think he's like yeah i think he's
stratosphere yeah i guess that's how i
saw john lovetts maybe yeah but as a kid
he always cracked me up yeah
well he's out there he's doing [ __ ]
right yeah he's in stuff he's he's in he
has six projects seven eight problems oh
my god look how many projects he has oh
well there we go we're just not keeping
up with this i guess i always like no
yeah he's he's working you think he was
just like i mean there's no way to
really he's on tons of tv he is he a
dick in real life
i don't know have you heard any stories
i have never really heard any stories no
can we see you i think if you if you
google is john loves like like i think
there's probably a story about everybody
out there
uh looks like him and andy dick aren't
getting along well i mean he gets along
with andy dick i think any dick feuds
with a lot of people does he i haven't
seen andy dick in a while last time i
saw andy dick was in person
at a club in la and he was getting
thrown out really yeah i always feel
like anything has a way about then he
does things that make me laugh i always
was always nervous to meet him because i
don't know he just seems like a true
wild card yeah like he might bite you or
like piss on you yeah yeah
but maybe that's not his mo i'm not
saying that he would do that right but
who knows i don't know i think he was i
think he's i think he has the uh yeah he
has he's pegged with what the rap would
be called a volatile personality yeah
yeah yeah that's what i always heard
about him i don't know
well there he is andy dick well god
bless we wish you all well yeah doesn't
remind me of deroza combined with
distefano
[Music]
oh my god
oh man oh my god andy dick is the rosa
combined with the stefano andy dick jeez
look at that hair
uh wow well yeah one of those like
method guys is that why he gets on the
people's skin i think he was just really
into drugs for a long time i think
that's i mean when when i was we were at
a club with uh andy milinakis this is
how long ago this was like uh andy's
great i haven't seen him in like 15
years he just moved to astoria oh he's
back yeah oh okay cool so i actually
think i reach out to him to be a guest
on this yeah i think i did he said
anytime i but it was over covered i
think we're going to do a zoom and then
it fell apart but he's really like uh he
has a lot of knowledge on sushi
and he does yeah yeah big time yeah so
how did you guys meet andy milnakas i
knew andy before 20 years ago oh really
when he was he was hanging out in jersey
with this group of friends that i was
before he had the tv show before he had
the andy milnaka show when he we always
thought he was
first of all he's so nice oh andy great
guy but he's just very funny and then
like out of nowhere
lynch was telling me like uh oh yeah
andy's got a tv show on mtv we're like
like it didn't even
like there was no like i didn't unders
like i was like and i was like yeah i
guess he did things on youtube or yeah i
think he was also at like in ucb or he
was like in the in the world yeah i mean
not saying he didn't deserve it i
thought he did it he just came out of
the field but it was literally like andy
was here one day we went to that greek
restaurant with him in in probably
astoria years and years ago and then i
heard he moved to i like when people do
that better than telling me what they're
doing yeah yeah and that was him and
he's so funny i still remember hit the
theme song to us so i i got keys on my
head but don't call me a p head yeah
he's on my head but don't know me at
least
now please excuse me i gotta get my wow
yeah i hang out with an apple who loves
self-loathing i hate myself
he used to get big names because that's
when mtv was blowing up he used to get
like huge names like
yeah
i remember he did a bit that i always
liked uh that was uh like he would have
pizza delivered and then tie himself to
a chair
i was like i'd be like it's the [ __ ]
and then he would drop
yeah you'd be like could you put the
slice in my mouth he's going good and
the pizza guy was always this [ __ ]
guy who probably didn't speak english
and he was just like uh all right man
and like it was so funny man i have a
couple of distinct andy uh memories
one time i felt really bad he had i
think he just got in the show and he was
staying at like they put him up and he
was in la at the standard or something
like that okay and we were a group of us
lynch was with us we hated that hotel
the standard but yeah yeah we were
hanging out and um
andy was so nice we went to i guess we
were in his hotel or whatever like we
were in the lobby or like i guess it's
like a scene yeah well back in the day
that's yeah that's that was it and uh
and he's like oh you know what we'll
just put it on my my tab because mtv you
know got it for me you know so it just
rolled it around the drink so i was like
all right you sure he's again i'm like i
have a margarita i said to the waitress
yeah and she goes cadillac
and i went sure
and i guess i didn't really realize that
them but the cadillac is like most
expensive yeah yeah and then this is
like i i i got to think this was
i don't know this has had to be like 15
yeah years more this is about more yeah
i don't know anyway when they brought
the bill over and he went to sign i saw
it and the my drink my one drink was
thirty two dollars
and this is again like twenty years ago
like we didn't have money no one didn't
like i would i would look at that now
and say excuse me you made a mistake
right that better be i thought it was
exactly 600 bottle of wine if you're
talking i felt so bad yeah but a funny
thing actually because i just got you to
start watching succession yeah yes
oh i didn't just get youtube but like
you're loving it right yeah you got me
to watch it because i heard it and you
kept saying you gotta watch it you gotta
watch you watch no no you gotta watch it
it's so good i'm halfway through the
third season it's good yeah uh so one
time i don't remember the circumstances
andy was oh maybe he lived in new york
if he lived or were we visiting we were
hanging out one night he was with some
friends i was with some friends we met
up we were bar hopping together and we
went to this uh bar in the lower east
side called
something shots
it was it was there a long time it was a
dive all right like
we've been there we've been there yeah
yeah something shots or whatever it was
it wasn't like the down the hatch area
no no that's west this was proper less
okay
something like i i mean i wish i knew
the name but it was like it was
you always like would end up there or
like whatever we went on this place
pretty dead no one's in there right we
go and we sit at the bar and we're with
like five six people we get our drinks
and i turned to my right the only other
person in there
at the bar drinking alone kieran culkin
get out of here now again this was
fifteen twenty yeah when he was just
recalling
he might have been in like it might have
already been like igb goes down he got i
i think i knew he was already acting he
wasn't just like i knew who he was okay
but i didn't god he's so good
yeah yeah so good right so good but uh i
didn't
no i wasn't going to bother him didn't
know what to say to him not one to
approach anyone send that man a cadillac
margarita but um but i noticed it was
him that's it i don't think i said
anything but i think he lived in the
hood because he knew the bartender was
like it almost uh was like the bartender
he was a regular okay like he was like
yeah and they call him by his name and
then i don't know if you get it and um
and i remember he goes let me get one
more shot
and so we we were doing shots we had
just walked in and i think that like
he was annoyed that four or five people
walked in and were drinking like i think
it was like he was in the zone yeah
because i i remember like we said
someone said a joke i distinctly
remember this and
uh
and and then i caught out of my eye that
he rolled his eyes to the bartender
really then i felt like so he's like
roman in real life no i don't know i
mean we might have been obnoxious or
yeah i'm sure right i don't think we
were but i think i saw him roll his eyes
and i felt stupid because i was like oh
like i like this guy like i'm a fan like
i'm just like oh did i [ __ ] do
something like did someone do something
to piss to annoy him so he just quickly
did his shot left the money and walked
out so i was like ah that's a bummer
yeah i don't think i mean he wasn't a
dick no he wasn't he didn't know i saw
it but whatever so i was like ah then
then a little bit later we left to go to
another bar and we were walking down the
avenue whatever avenue was on a or
whatever the hell and and then he was
walking past us the other direction he
had gone to the store and bought a
six-pack heineken and he was carrying it
going back the other way so i guess he
was just going to drink alone i don't
know man i don't know
uh i mean i don't know i don't know i
used to go to this bar called smalls
where they let you bring your own so
maybe it was a situation like that or
maybe just going home wanted be here
but um yeah i didn't even make like like
sorry sir contact i hate that feeling so
there was uh so you were out with andy
is that what you were saying yeah yeah i
don't know how we got into i know we
didn't shout out andy milner oh yeah
yeah good guy nice guy but how do we get
i don't know i forget uh how we got to
this point but we have a lightning round
oh andy dick to aunt to milonakis yeah
who knows but we got lightning here we
go okay let's go uh welcome to t-a-s-t-e
buzz okay and today we're doing a quick
lightning round with the theme of we
have a carnival yeah uh fair type of
theme right yeah carnival fair and so
we're doing three battles it's gonna be
a lightning lightning battle three
rounds uh so we're doing cracker jacks
versus crunch and munch sure we are
going to do cotton candy versus funnel
cakes yep we're gonna do a haunted house
versus roller coaster right so we got a
little theme going we'll start off with
i say we saved that one to last okay i
want to start off with uh oh how long do
we have five minutes five minutes okay
five five is five or eight it was five
but we can we gotta do five five all
right
i do whatever you want we'll do eight
two derose is usually the one who
enforces this five minutes oh okay like
he'll go and then i'll be trying to get
mine in and he'll cut me shut yeah okay
that's the whole point of the lightning
round though you go fast and furious got
you okay you know we love that yeah we
do
all right fast and furious quarter mile
at a time that's it dom toretto
uh you want to do uh
crackerjack crunchin munch sure okay
yeah would you like to start should i
dealer's choice okay i think that
crackerjack was the original and i think
that they got lazy
and i think that they did not
adapt to the times well what is the
crunch in munch breakfast
punch is
similar to a cracker jack it's sold in
buttery toppings well you'll find
cracker jack more so you'll find cracker
jack in the supermarket but you'll find
cracker jackets sporting events and
concerts yeah that's a plus crunchy
bunch i don't think you'll find there
you'll find them mostly in the
supermarket but it is the same exact
thing except they adapted to the times
and i also what do you mean they adopted
to the time well let me finish my
everything
jack uh they they have gotten shin see
over the years in all three departments
okay okay four departments
box is smaller than it used to be
the caramel coating on the popcorn is
if i'm telling you it's
sparse yeah
i'm being i'm being kind okay it's if
you could get a handful you still see
all the specks of white all over those
kernels because they are not coated okay
okay it's a light coating yeah peanuts
peanuts are the cheapest nut yeah they
give you peanut quarters or peanut
halves yeah they are not they're so
little caramel coating on the cracker
jack that the peanut does not stick to
it you're looking for cluster that's
what they're used to big ammo you get
both in one bite right now if i open a
box of cracker jacks they're off
eight measly peanut halves at the bottom
of that thing you gotta shake it and i
gotta pick around the peanuts anyway so
that's fine for you you do you don't
like peanut butter i'm sorry am i
supposed to be letting you go no you
could do no no no you can jump in you
cut me off you could shout out oh all
right yeah i just i just one question
what prize comes with a crunching much
well let me tell you something does any
prize come with a crunch fair enough i
knew you would take that stance but of
course i take this that's the whole
cracking jack in this stage
this day and age i think you should look
in the mirror because what price comes
with a cracker jack they [ __ ] to bed
there too they got little books they got
no tattoos no no not anymore i think
it's for [ __ ] now the prize isn't but
it'll be exciting a tattoo i love it
yeah they still got tattoos they got two
books they don't do it anymore they
don't do it anymore the new prizes suck
ass
yes please just find out now but
first of all the peanut means nothing to
me i got to pick my way around the
peanuts no matter what yeah but the
cracker jack is to everyone out there is
their whole their whole business model
is peanuts
no cracker jack's business model is
childhood
and joy
cruncher much doesn't deliver that to
you i i go for a cracker jack i remember
coming out of school walking to the pops
meal mobile ordering cracker jack eating
the eating the caramel you got me
understanding the thing right
but nostalgia can only get you so far
look at this someone even did it look at
okay look at that the cracker jacks are
on the right see that picture pimp throw
this up too yeah cracker jacks are on
the right see the big holes of caramel
missing you see those
same holes in the left four measly
peanuts at the bottom the same things
are on the left the same exact rules you
have a crunchy munch your balls will be
blown off and you will never go back to
crackerjack crunch and munch you
literally have to break off like it's a
brick they coat it so well that that
that's too much that's gonna get stuck
in your tooth you're gonna go chewing
moderation okay it can hurt you you're
gonna get so now i got now i don't even
have anything to do with the definitions
because i got no prize hold on hold on a
thumb there would have been a tooth i
can't believe you don't know crunching
much because let me tell you what
cruncher munch did they will take not
only caramel they'll take toffee
they will take other
other sweets to cook and they will also
switch up the nuts well don't spray [ __ ]
on me and tell me it's perfume yeah but
look buttery toffee with popcorn and
peanuts go to all the cru
chocolate and caramel okay this just
sounds like insecurity they're putting
out yeah give me give me this there's
one with almonds
dude this is gonna just google
these people the master of nothing you
go to crack look what you've just told
me is that when you go for a bag of
crunchy much you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're gonna get not true you don't
know whether you're gonna get caramel
you don't know where you're gonna get
this nonsense that's that's a little
flavor i go from cracking jack i know
what i'm getting i know how it's going
to taste because it tastes that way for
50 years and i know i'm getting a nice
little prize out of it used to taste
better when we were kids right now if i
do succumb to a crackerjack purchase at
a ball game so come yes if i do i'm old
wait you're saying crack attack has
nothing for you not any longer
no i'm telling you right now i'm not out
of here yeah first of all i can't you've
never had crunch and munch no i've never
had you can't even argue against it if i
if i give you crunch and much right now
on your first mouthful
i get it i get it this is better than
cracker jack fries it's all about the
price and you know what there's nothing
you we shouldn't be eating crunchy much
at our age
it's over for us okay i will tell you
right now that back in the day yeah
maybe the prize
you could skirt squeak out a win on the
prize but the prizes have changed no the
tattoo's a little little joke books now
man well you got no joy last time you
did it i had crackers is it five minutes
all right sorry about that oh five or
five we gotta move on to the next
lightning round i guess that's that's
something i'm telling you they have 12
flavors of crunch and munchies
i hate to be a derozan
shut the [ __ ] up we're going to follow
the rules so because society's breaking
down i'll tell you what if unless crunch
and munch is a regional candy i think
country munch is gonna dominate the
polls because
i'm telling you nostalgia can't get you
over the finish line dude people who
have tried both
okay nobody's doing that nobody's doing
that this is my declaration if there is
a human being out there that has tried
both okay they will never take cracker
jack over control i can't i think you
have that 99
we shouldn't say things like that
because you have a show here based on
opinion and you you're damaging your
credibility you say [ __ ] like that
absolutes all the time yeah but that
doesn't matter that's derozan i'm
talking about you i'm not concerned
about him i would venture to say that
when we go to the polls yeah when we go
to the phones yeah i think that you'll
never you will not see a tweet that says
you know
i've had both and i like crackerjacks
you don't think you'll see that tweet
when i get i'm never satisfied at the
end of my crackerjacks i'm never
satisfied it's a temporary like this is
better than nothing but at the end i
don't my socks aren't blown off this fan
wrote in this poll is for old people
question munch is for kids dude crunch
and munch is not
it's not good look at that crunchy must
taste like packing peanut and cardboard
had a baby and tried to salvage it by
dousing it in caramel that's not true
but guess what they did not say anything
about the cracker jack oh my god dude
come on
oh wait we're going to the polls now
oh let's do polls after each one because
that is a thing dude i think you you you
you
you're too comfortable in life
all right you're in your ivory tower you
forget how exciting that [ __ ] prize
is
you forget how exciting that prize is
i'm telling you right now every day is a
prize for you it's not that way for
everybody else too obviously some people
only get prizes from crackerjack and
you're trying to take that away from it
okay so our viewers and listeners sound
off if you think the prizes have took a
hit if you think the prizes are [ __ ] if
they were better when we were younger or
let me know what your prize was look in
the comments the last time you eat
cracker jacks because i'm telling you it
ain't gang let me ask you something the
the song is not buy me some peanuts and
crunch and much the song locked in
american
society is buy me peanuts and cracker
jack and that is oh since the 1930s
they've been singing and i know and in
the 30s
communism in the 30s crackerjack was a
big dick swinging yeah it still is it
still is the big dick swinging but not
anymore man it is still in the song
look at what says americana look at this
a sailor boy this dog on a baseball with
a red white and blue box
come on man not a clue what either of
these are but a quick google has me
questioning why on earth have cracker
jacks let a 10 year old boy join the
nato that's not what happened you idiot
who said that that is not what happened
chloe i take it back you know listen
that is not what happened his father
is in the navy
and his father tell me right now that
you're not making this i'm not making
this up you know this of course it's
crackerjack you know the backstory
though everybody does how do you sign it
uh
oh i need to know i need to know yeah
sailor jack and bingo is the name of the
dog
oh my god they're from 1916.
come on man what are you doing salejack
was modeled at the robert
ruckheim grandson of frederick blah blah
blah blah blah cell boy image acquired
such meaning for the founder crackerjack
he had it carved onto his tombstone
which is insane nobody is ever putting
crunching much on their tombstone even
you won't put crunch and much on your
tombstone
oh go to the trivia what does this
trivia say
okay
in 1912 toy surprises were first put
into every crack oh what's that
tradition continued until frito lay
process it can't be i'm telling you
there's no more that's bad that was one
of my big complaints i forgot it i knew
it was like it's gotta be back him
gotta be back now because i remember i
was at the yankee game with lederman and
we got cracker jacks they were on the
arm it's got to be back i couldn't even
complain i couldn't even complain and
then i was got to the bottom like yo
where is the prize and they were like no
they don't do prizes anymore i'm like
that was all they had
all they had was the prize digital codes
give me a break give me a break break me
with a piece of that kitkat off that's
rough digital codes that is so
you're gonna you're gonna have a staple
from 1912 that still exists the with the
same label today and you're going to
tell people to go online and punch in a
digital code by the way to get what
you're right about that you're right
about that what are they going to give
you on a digital code nft
of bingo take me out to the ball game
was written in 1908
oh
wait a minute hold on a second now
the the last article said it was founded
in 1916. yeah this article said they
started putting toys in in 1912.
the next thing says
take me out to the ball game was written
in 1908 oh they probably they probably
adjusted the song i imagine like once
cracker jack came out i bet you crack
jack was named after that and then i got
adopted into the song
i don't know 18 oh my god jesus dude
take it back
cracker jack
was founded in
1896. i mean it's your dad's it's your
grandfather's
she said it was old people but she know
what she's talking about because do me a
favor google the cruncher munch the
beginnings of crunch and munch i got to
tell you crap
when we were kids by the way
yeah i never i never liked that i don't
even like the name of it uh i will say
this crackerjack if you're listening and
i know you are
oh he's getting a little
you gotta get them prizes back in guys i
i predicated my entire argument i came
to this knowing i had the prize in my
back pocket you guys are giving me
digital codes okay okay guys i will tell
you right now guys that it's nothing to
slouch out slouch at crunchy munch but
it came 70 years after cracker jack and
it was started in 1966 when i said you
know let me read this in 1980 uh okay
blah blah blah blah blah blah
in 2004 how about 2004 the new york
yankees baseball team replaced cracker
jack which has a strong molasses flavor
stronger
stronger strong stronger with the milder
buttery
buttery crunch and munch in home games
the club switch back to crack a jack
after immediate public outcry i'm
telling you you're not going to win this
crackerjack has a place in the american
heart yeah yeah my fear is that people
aren't going to know what crunch munch
is
apparent my fear is that people aren't
going to know what cracker jack is you
want to do it right now let's check it
out i think we're doing now all right
let's do it right now where you going
pimpy you don't crunch too much pimple
now i do i've never had okay it's so
good guys
come on
it's gonna be cracking it has to be
cracker jack
yeah
oh my god that's derosa de stefano
all right all right at the 5 400 votes
we got cracker jacks coming in at 62.3
percent drumroll i didn't do it
crunching months at 37.7
yeah i'll take the win but with the
caveat that crackerjack's got to listen
up and and get those prizes yeah yeah
that's a shame okay
that's a shame that's something else
i i want crunchy munch now
let me tell you the ones with the
almonds yeah oh i'll give it a shot
sounds good the problem with it honestly
the problem with caramel covered
potatoes [ __ ] teeth because i will
just not stop eating it i know i don't i
have to pick the peanuts out but i won't
stop eating you know what i haven't had
in a while you know those tins that look
like a goddamn oil drum yeah with the
with the three that's what i'm talking
about i had that a couple of months ago
yeah what is it it's butter cheese and
caramel that's what it is right it's
it's exactly the best camera and i had
that when he's got the cardboard
three-way divider and that makes those
shits and uh
my god i just ate the whole thing yeah
it's disgusting yeah they give it to you
in like literally what looks like it
looks like a five gallon bucket i hate
to say this because cause cause we're
recording this two days before christmas
we like to uh you know i don't know
behind the curtain yeah all right and i
you know i spend i i spend christmases
by myself because i go to pennsylvania
at my parents house and then i come back
because the cats and then i'm not
driving all the way back there it's two
hours i do christmas eve i do christmas
by myself okay every year right for a
decade now christmas by myself
i am this year going to hunt down one of
those three try-away popcorn things and
you could rest assured that my christmas
will be spent working my way through
that and watching the new machines one
of you guys has that in your home right
now yeah tweet us taste buds
popcorn bucket yeah i want to see you
eat it uh you should hit that up i don't
think you can get that i didn't get that
like the christmas tree shop yeah yeah
oh yeah they probably have a display in
the front that looks like a pyramid they
sell it at like marshalls can amazon
can amazon overnight it to me oh i know
actually i know you love popcorn right
do we have a popcorn against anything do
we ever put popcorn against anything
we did pretzel versus potato chip right
we did movie snacks but you did we
didn't do cheese doodle we did we did
pretzel versus because he loves popcorn
i i'm not a huge popcorn fan really yeah
i i eat it like four nights a week
it gets stuck in my like you're always
like oh there's this thing i can't get
out in your teeth and then i taste it
for like hours after but you get chips
without chips
do you know you get a crunch without the
yeah yeah maybe a healthier option i
mean and also when it's buttery what you
got it yeah how much was it it's 25.99
25. i was gonna say i was gonna say i
bet you you're getting ripped off at
11.99 oh well
well i had to do with everyone that
could deliver right away that was the
problem
oh my god it's just popcorn where did
they get the balls so many because it's
all about so close to christmas i have
to i have this there's a late run on him
yeah yeah we just triggered him into
this purchase that's right i'm not even
getting anything man i'm watching matrix
and housing this thing in my [ __ ]
bread box on christmas that's the other
thing with popcorn i don't like it but
when it is buttery and salty i'll eat
that [ __ ] full bucket at the movie
theater and then i will hate myself well
movie theater popcorn is not really that
good for you because it's all coconut
oil and it is it's like one bucket is
like 2 000 calories probably more you
get an air popper even if you want to
have that half a stick of butter it's
still it's still like for 400 calories
you could double right across the whole
thing put some salt
i got an air popper and i have i just
got a uh i just ordered a gourmet batch
of
amish
like popcorn you got quite a you've got
kelvin tonight ahead of you
i did it for the holidays yeah it's nice
that's nice stuff all right all right
well then what did they honestly i'll
report
sally babe we're here for the ads it's
good to see you we haven't been together
in a minute it's been a little minute
we've had the holidays
yeah we have and after today's episode
i'll be back in that saddle right next
to you are you looking forward to that
oh i can't wait yeah we're supposed to
record some tomorrow again right yeah
yeah all right i think in a business
speaking of businesses can i talk to you
about all birds babe
talk to me about all burbs and but but
more importantly than all birds talk to
me specifically about their wool dasher
mizzle
well
it's uh it's cool that you brought that
up but because even though we are in a
wet chili part of the year
running are still a part of people's
lives maybe not mine in yours you know
but the wool dasher missile is a weather
repellent performance running shoe it's
the first shoe of its kind it's
sustainably made from natural materials
with the low environmental impact on the
planet because that is where we should
all be going right now ideally uh you
know
look here's let me let me explain i have
a pair of roll birds i got my dad a pair
my mom and my my grandmother are there
because i got them before i really knew
what they were
and i knew about the company and i put
them on i could not believe because you
know my feet aren't
they're done
they just they're just a bunch of mixed
up bones and a sack of flesh down there
i have no arch and i i wear custom
orthotics i tried on all birds dude i
swear to you they were light breathable
yeah and they were suit my feet don't
hurt when i'm in them so it's almost
like
it's almost like remember when remember
when that craze was happening where
people were wearing the the like the
like toe sock things
yeah and you looked like a lunatic
walking around those things and i but
they were comfortable i feel that all
birds has found a stylish way to feel
that comfortable
the
missile the big thing about these is i
don't actually have these but they are
they keep their feet warm and they're
weather repellent so they're really good
for the winter months
yes yes uh i think that's great uh
especially if you live in a city or in a
cold weather environment like new york
gets in in the winter it's great to have
a shoe that's warm but also comfortable
and not a big clunky boot
so i mean that's the thing man that's
how you got to do it
and have you run in them do you want to
do you want to run in them yes you do
will you run in them that's up to you
but i can tell you if you want to run in
them they will perform for you if you
perform for them they need performance
so this winter keep your feet cozy and
dry with all birds wool dasher missiles
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com today that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot com
taste buddies what's up it's ship
station time
now you guys might not know what ship
station is this is you can do if you
have a business or you got to mail stuff
out from home it's basically like having
the post office right in your house
you can use all forms of of shipments uh
from home
and it's a lot cheaper than using them
in person a lot of businesses use this
for the holiday rush they had even
though there was shipping delays and
supply shortages and all the holiday
demand it was a mess
but ship station was one of the
solutions to that and now with the new
year coming in guys you got your
impatient customers they want returns
there's expensive shipping rates what
you're going to do is check out ship
station
ship
show
ship station i can attest to how good
this service is because i in fact
i lived in a post office for some time
and it was the most convenient time of
my life well so it's nice that now ship
station is bringing the post office home
to me i love the time it saves i can say
i mean there's nothing worse than going
to the post office let's be honest i
mean it's up there with the dmv you know
so station is the easiest and most
convenient choice for all you ecommerce
sellers what you're selling out there
ecommerce people
we're going to start selling merch
and maybe and maybe we're going to start
using ship station as a matter of fact
yeah there you go you can save money
i've used this service for personal
reasons and uh it's just been
like i said there's just nothing i hate
standing in lines i hate how much it
costs i hate then this takes away all of
that and lets you do it out of your
house so
trust me whether it's professional or
personal you want to use ship station
use the offer code taste buds to get a
60-day free trial
that's pretty weird that's two months
free no hassles you know and stress free
shipping whatever what do you people
want go to shipstation.com ship more in
less time right that's what they again
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in taste
buds of course
ship station make make ship have
happened
what do we got we're going to cotton
candy versus funnel cake now okay i i
feel you're going to lose this one too
man
cause funnel cake is
nothing more than just fried dough but
what's better than fried anything and
especially fried dough powdered sugar
right so you're taking cotton candy yeah
i'm taking funnel cake right please go
ahead okay here's the thing though
funnel cake is just
it's the fried dough delicious with just
put sugar on that there's also 20
variations of that at that same conical
one staple like a shot it's star
this one's shaped like this a dagger
zeppelin all these things there's
nothing special to it there is only one
cotton candy that's it you're not you're
not getting your substitute any other
way well when you call them different
they're different shapes but there's
only one fried dough with powdered sugar
i mean they could be different shapes
yeah but you're still the same item
well no you've chosen funnel cakes okay
so i'm just saying a phone there's
nothing special about a funnel cake
there's a zeppelin there's no
proprietary nothing proprietary
you can make it at home i can't make
some [ __ ] kind i think out of all the
fried dough with confectionery sugars
i mean we're from new york so i think
zeppeli's are sold at pizzerias they put
them in a brown bag and they shake them
like they do a cafe yeah whatever what
do they call them a cafe dumont they
don't call themselves uh beignets right
it's all the same thing yeah right
here's the thing though
if you're gonna make like a fairy tale
world
the clouds are not made
of fried dough fries
nothing says fair
carnival
childhood freaky it's so out of the
wheelhouse of your everyday experience
cotton candy you see cotton candy you
know you're in a fun place i would argue
the same exact thing for funnel cakes
come on man this is this is this is a
carnival lightning round i i
where do you get a funnel cake if not
under the carnival you can make funnel
cake downstairs right now i can make
cotton candy how can you make hunt cakes
they sell the things to make what the
machinery they sell them yeah you can't
so aka you can't make cotton candy first
of all they sell spaceships that doesn't
mean anything first of all funnel cakes
are hot yeah that's a huge plus what's
better on a hot summer night than a hot
[ __ ] fried dough in your gullet i
love i think funnel cakes are the
superior product out of all fried dough
treats it comes on a paper plate it fits
the whole plate it's fun it has
delicious it has all the interlocking
laces so the texture is different the
the powdered sugar gets in all the nooks
and crannies it's fun to break apart and
eat piecemeal yeah it's warm it comes
fresh usually when you order a funnel
cake you don't it's made to order like a
cotton candy yeah no not necessarily
that yeah they put them in those [ __ ]
bags and they have yeah you could also
get that you could also get fun cakes
like that too who's ordering a funnel
cake pre-made you're getting it hot oh
come on they have they haven't stacked
up in the in the in the glass cases no
no no no you're telling me that nobody
has funnel case stocked up and glasses
no no no the point is that they are hot
they have to be eaten hot in a in an
ideal situation i will grant you that
the carnival association of america will
make sure that all of your funnel cakes
are hot but i don't think that that that
quality control is going on too
you're talking about carnies guys who
forget to put things in right strong
disagree
i think you you order a funnel cake to
order they dunk it in that thing they
pull it out and they put the powdered
sugar on they hand it over and there's
grease on the plate because it's just
fine yeah but more often than not more
of a i feel you're being dizzy genius
more often than not part of the cotton
candy experience is that all right hold
on let me just finish is that another
thing i like about the funnel cake is
there you can grab a piece that has got
extra crispy that has a crunch to it or
an undercooked piece i even love the
undercooked more doughy pieces i love
the difference in texture uh you know
you could shake the sugar off to if you
want to sure control you the sugar
intake yeah you know what i mean so i i
just variations okay so cause sugar or
if you eat all that sugar it's too much
right but
conversely cotton candy is 100
pure sugar and nothing else well it's
dreams
it's joy it's childhood joy you know
cotton candy is the biggest scam ever
come on you put it in your mouth it and
it melts i know it melts like it was air
like you never really bought anything
to make you feel like you're getting a
real deal what are we talking about the
cotton candy goes like this and you're
like as a kid you're like oh my god of
course if you want to grab it all in
your fist and squeeze it to this big
popping you're out it'll be melted in
five and how great was it when you could
discover that
like that was a an option for cotton
candy you could stick your mouth in it
do that and let it melt in all right
what are you talking about puffs
get in there you get the little part
okay it is a it is a fun tactile
experience on your fingers a little bit
i'll give you that it's a fun tactile
experience pink it's green it's better i
i hate the stickiness i hate it on my
fingers and even more so i hate it
around my lips and then you it doesn't
go away you have to get find a water
fountain or you have to find a wipe or
what like a
so you have an issue with cotton candy
being messy but not funnel cake yeah i'm
talking like i don't need this right it
looks like you have dandruff all over
you i can dust off powdered sugar yeah
the cotton candy is that [ __ ] and if you
eat it as an adult with a beer or a
mustache you're done nobody has it ever
described the funnel cake as whimsical
no one but i guarantee that even you
could not disagree that cotton candy has
a certain whimsical element to it that
life is life is
we all need a little more whimsy in our
lives
we all get fooled by the dye
we get food though that's part of it
cotton candy was just white
it's not
i know but like
i think it's not i don't give a [ __ ] if
it was this and if it was that i think
cotton candy's smoking mirrors
that's what i think it is they puff it
up they put in a big bag they have five
minutes
in gets all melted
you can pretend it's a witch's nose
after you're done with it it's
phenomenal you know sticky a family of
four could go in on a funnel cake a
family of four can absolutely go in on
cotton candy of course they can it's
more sustenance though at the end of the
day i'm not trying to [ __ ] feed my
family i'm trying to have a good time at
the fair
where's the value where are you getting
more bang for your dollar a funnel cake
has some weight to it
you're eating you're eating glorified
air as cotton candy you're eating pizza
without the [ __ ] cheese and without
the sauce with a funnel cake it's just
fried dough man it's not that there are
balls they have to charge five bucks for
something like that you're making that
up you don't know that they're charging
how much they charge for the cotton
candy they don't change them i don't
know but i'm not stating it as if i do
know is my point
you're buying the experience man come on
you don't really feel this way it also
gets old you can't be this miserable
cotton candy cotton candy first bite
fun yeah cotton candy 15 16 bite yeah
i don't want it anymore okay what yeah
how you but the whole funnel cake you'll
eat that's no problem that doe just i
think it's hard not to fill in your
stomach i know i'm not saying i don't
you know i shouldn't eat the whole time
i don't know dude and sometimes i know
the like the grease on the funnel cake
also soaks in the the sugar a little bit
and makes it a little more lassie cakey
yeah i don't really like it oh i like
that
it's not really my thing man i like i
like whimsy man i like whimsical
experiences and for me cotton candy and
the the witch knows afterwards give it
to me
all right another one anti-cotton candy
thing is it was invented by a dentist
i saw that which blew my balls off i
like dentists that's a hustle though i
know that's all right yeah you know what
they were doing they had they had full
appointments that year that they
invented it when they invented cotton
candy they were also giving you like
cocaine for headaches so i'm not sure
like that was the time i think you're
gonna lose this one like hard i know
because i think people have an affinity
to cotton candy they don't have
but if you're really asking when the
chips are down what's better i think it
is funnel cake well all right i don't
know what even that means when the chips
are down i don't know what chips are
going on we're gonna go to the phone all
right cotton candy is like eating hair
that's also true except i don't like
that it's like
except it dissolves and you get to eat
even more it's great i've never
understood why anybody likes it
funnel cakes are too much like pancakes
and pancakes make me nauseous
i would like to powdered sugar off it
though lick it for that reason alone i'd
choose cotton candy nothing's better
than deep fried dough it's true it's
getting powdered sugar
funnel cake was so good they're like can
we wrap this around things
and then they wrapped it around hot dogs
and they wrapped it around oreos deep
fried they deep fry everything they
wrapped it you turned a corndog
yeah but they also have this cornmeal oh
all right maybe i'm it's messed up don't
they also
don't they also do like funnel cake mix
around a hot dog i don't know man i
don't i don't know enough about funnel
cakes besides that yeah well whenever
you deep fry those things like oreos
it's all the heavy lifting is because of
the funnel cake and the powder like
those deep fried oreos are just
glorified funnel cakes with oreos in
them well i'm getting lost here i don't
know where we're going
i don't know where your angle is yeah
you can't make a deep fried oreo if you
don't have all the trimmings of a funnel
cake that's why i don't yeah okay so i'm
just saying
oil cake is so good
no no no they when they deep fry an oreo
they put it in the the same batter as
the funnel cake yeah but as we've
previously discussed that batter is in
many things not just funnel cakes yeah
but it's it's it's funnel cakes
exclusivity it's their proprietary blend
no no no no no no we you we started this
whole thing off by saying that
the thing that makes up funnel cakes
makes up many things in my in my eyes so
it's a beignet mix it's not a [ __ ]
banana and the zebra are the same
exactly
what i'm telling you is it's such a good
thing that they're like what can we wrap
this in and deep fry that to along with
it popcorn rosa would disqualify this
argument a hundred percent really i
think he would i want to speak for
derozan here i think he's he would say
this would be an add-on
he is he is but like he you but but it
allows me to bring up cotton candy
flavored uh uh gum
ice cream oh also they they've
translated that there is favorite ice
cream you know yeah okay birthday cake i
am not arguing for the fried oreo i'm
just saying that the funnel cake is so
good that they took the best yeah but
i'm just saying that
cotton candy's so good that they've
spread that around too cotton candies
for children who need a sugar rush
funnel cake is for adults with taste
okay
adults with taste at carnies
you got you thank you if you're over 10
years old and you eat cotton candy
you're a serial killer wow that is
[ __ ] harsh funnel cakes all day maybe
i'm gonna get my [ __ ] ass kicked here
funnel cake you can have more often at
occasions and such cotton candy you'll
get a local carnival once or twice a
year
oh
that's an argument for cotton candy it's
more you have it less
yeah cotton candy is what terrible
parents give to their terrible children
in hopes they'll be less terrible you
have a very judgmental audience here man
well they know to weigh in with they
they know they do not hold their
opinions back wow i i thought i had this
and now i feel like i don't we're gonna
go to uh drum roll humble pie uh we got
8 000 votes right now pimps weighing in
with a funnel cake
oh
baby oh baby no pun intended but how
sweet it is
oh wow okay okay
you lost the first one oh my god it's a
drubbing it's a problem
you won the first one no you won the
chris stefano one you won the christmas
sorry yes yeah you won the last
lightning round though you just won with
crackerjack crackerjack one but i will
say that in our last few episodes
actually
um
but this is uh
over the episodes you and i have done so
far yeah this is the biggest margin
70.6 of the funnel cake 29.4
to the cotton candy now why do you think
that is why do you think
i wasn't trying to be smarmy i was like
why would it be weighted that heavily
if we thought cotton candy was going to
have the same attributes as cracker jack
it was going to appeal to the nostalgia
the you know and
you know it's it it is a carnival food
it is well yeah it is i think perhaps
quintessential maybe cotton candy is
just limited
in in what it offers you
whereas perhaps funnel cakes offer more
just offer more okay all right you know
well here we go because the lighting
round is tied 1-1
so okay the overall match will be taken
here in the rubber match okay which is
going to be the i don't think please i
don't think we told each other that
we'll still love each other by the way
oh we'll do it at the very end of the
app okay yeah
okay i love that i was worried did we do
the chances we did attlee buds oh no we
didn't do all right
we did the asd buds yeah really derose
is the driving force of the chance we
could ignore it then no no i'm saying
that's why i'm falling off okay i'm
disrespectful to the rosa i think right
so we've got all right so we just feel
like for the rubber match yeah okay we
are ready to b-a-t-t-l-e
buds
i i wasn't ready okay and i don't i
never know whether you're going to taste
a battle i i i taste up top with the
pause battle later no pause i always
forget to okay good but we did it we're
gonna end with the chance all right
so
whether it's saving more and spending
less or getting organized or losing
weight
or whatever things and goals and
resolutions we set for ourselves at this
time of year every year all right
top of the list for me
something new
yeah pable all right we've been talking
about babel for a minute but now is the
time more than ever you want to learn
that new language you want to stick to
that new year's resolution to expand
your horizons
now's the time and you can do it with
babel it sold
the company sold more than 10 million
subscriptions yeah it's an app on your
phone it's a language learning app uh
they make it fun they make it so like
you could actually use it and feel like
you're instead of just mindlessly
playing a game or whatever it actually
feels like you can have fun with it and
learn the language that's kind of what i
like about it it's engaging
and they teach it in ways that really
are
applicable it's not just like drilling
memory which i which i like a lot about
it and we talk about it all the time
there's 14 languages and it was created
by language experts where some of the
other apps they use ai so it's a
different experience and the lessons are
distilled down to 15 minutes which i do
it like a lot of times i'll do it on the
on the uh subway
or you know just if i'm in an uber i
thought i was going to get a little
crash for a second there and then you
said something ah
the old
subway
uh plus the uh speech recognition
technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent i think that's a big part of it i
think a big part of people feeling
intimidated to learn a new language is
them feeling that they won't be able to
do the pronunciation and the accent
correctly or or
you feel a little self-conscious you
know because it's not it's not territory
it's also not just the lessons which i
don't know if you talk about that a lot
but you can access podcasts games videos
live classes and a 20-day money-back
guarantee so there's no reason not to
try you have nothing to lose right now
when you purchase a three-month babble
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use our promo code
tastebuds that's b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com code taste buds babel language
language for life right sally babe it's
the new year and i want to talk to you
about headspace i want to talk to the
listeners about headspace uh
do you ever feel like your mind doesn't
have an off switch i have a feeling the
answer is yes sal because i know it
doesn't absolutely
you guys hear what we argue about on
this show imagine what the brain is
doing in our heads when it gets into the
serious topic i'm in a mental prison
true
life sentence
uh you can sometimes have this manifest
through your body too like i'll feel the
tension i'll feel tired no matter how
much i sleep yeah i get into these these
these i don't want to call them routines
they're almost ruts
um
and you know these are just a few ways
that stress and anxiety and sleep
disease can can harm the mind and the
body and it's just not a place you want
to be so it's a new year this year why
not make the small change to your daily
routine
these small changes that can have huge
influences on your mental health and
well-being that's what headspace is here
to do we all say fine when we don't
really mean it i know i do yeah how you
doing i'm good i'm good uh fine isn't
really an emotion is it how many times
have you told yourself fine when you
really all you've really felt is anger
or sadness or nerves headspace is
scientifically proven to help you manage
your feelings and your mental health
in fact a recent study proved in just
two weeks headspace can reduce your
stress by 14
yeah it's great you want to relieve
stress or anxiety sleep better or
improve focus headspace is your everyday
dose of mindfulness for real life
whenever i'm feeling
heavy quotes fine
see what i did there yeah uh i like
using headspace's appreciation course it
it it instantly makes me feel a bit
happier about what matters in my life
that's what i think is great about
um
a service like this is because
so much of our lives is focusing
especially in the culture we live in is
focusing on the things that we don't
have
the things the other person has what's
missing from our lives
it's unhealthy we're scrolling through
social media and all these things and
we're just seeing everybody's hashtag
best life selfies and whatever and it
can really start to get into your head
and one thing that headspace has helped
me with is appreciating what i have
realizing what's important so however
you're feeling
try it out just try it you might not
even realize you're having some of these
issues
headspace give it a try at headspace.com
taste buds you're going to get one month
for free
off the entire mind mindfulness library
so i don't see what you ever have to
lose here one month free
this is the best head space offer
available so go to headspace.com
taste buds today headspace.com tastebuds
it's appropriate now because this is
down and dirty it's the dirt it's a
tie-breaking match i think i got this
we're doing roller coaster versus
haunted house again to go with our
carnival theme
q is taking haunted house i am taking
roller coaster
discuss
you don't hear a lot of people dying in
haunted houses one
two i worked at sand lane amusement park
for two summers and i i as a 16 year old
child was in charge of maintenance on
both those rides and i could tell you
that those [ __ ] roller coasters are
not safe okay they're not safe and
they're being they're being uh the carny
type ones uh they are being you know
maintained by children like myself oh
though oh yeah the carnival ones yeah i
mean i i guess that's a that's a good
point to make a good distinction uh
you're not talking you're not talking
rolling thunder
no no i i i i although you can i guess
rolling
roller coaster has any okay but i know
those carny ones sometimes they fold
them out of the back of a box oh it's
insane and then not even weighted
properly yeah and then
and i think that's part of the problem
with roller coasters is because
there are the greats yeah but
all the other roller coasters are kind
of riding on the
roller coasters seriously doesn't they
hurt your neck when you're on them they
can but i think that's part of the
battle yeah i've gotten whiplash on a
couple yeah uh the one what's that one
where
uh i don't know my head slammed i mean i
jacked myself up on yeah like great
adventure and i actually went one time
to uh hershey park where it was like um
the evening already so it was like a
limited like pay little bit and nobody
was there right and so i was able to go
on every roller coaster they had which i
think was seven or eight within like no
within under an hour and i was
vastly nauseous yeah yeah i didn't
understand that your equilibrium is gone
yeah and look i like a roller coaster i
do
but there's something to a haunted house
that is otherworldly and they could tell
a story in a haunted house and and like
well now you now you go into like a
disney haunted house because if what
you're going to carnival no let's talk
pros and cons if you're going to talk
about the box truck roller coaster ride
the carnival's haunted house
is a shame
well not all of them are it's a horn a
flashing light not all air blowing in
your face yeah you know like a strobe
light comes on there are some miserable
ones there are some miserable that is
just like you go in a corner and they've
dangled some strings on you and i guess
but we can we can agree that there's a
bottom level on both of those
but i think the general one is like you
go to the jersey shore and it's on the
boardwalk and it's a little bit better
you know what i mean like it takes you
around they do yes
yes the disney haunted house is
obviously the ultimate version of that
let's discount that they still do manage
to tell you a story and manage to give
you an experience well they will scare
you in a way that roller coasters won't
scare you well
roller coasters so this is an
interesting dichotomy because they both
offer thrills yeah and they both offer
scares yeah for different reasons yes so
i guess it could be preference
but what i'm saying is first of all i
don't like haunted houses you don't i'm
scared of them yeah i i'm not scared of
them but i don't like being jumped i
don't like when someone jumps out grabs
my ankle jumps out of nowhere scares me
i think it takes i think it takes some
years of my life
i am afraid that my reflexes will i will
literally punch someone yeah i don't
like it because i get a headache because
my adrenaline is pumping so much
and look i will say though there's
nothing like that feeling when you
well you could be walking into one or
you could be on the trolley i assume the
trolley we're talking about as well but
there is nothing like that feeling when
you hit past those swinging doors and
then it's pure darkness yeah that's a
good feeling but it's a good feeling
does that match the feeling of tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
and
that feeling where you're plateauing
yeah right there i mean
a haunted house with all its
redundancies of boo yeah really match
all the different permutations that a
roller coaster could take you on both in
loop-de-loop drop speed uh
torque uh um theme yeah uh theme's
important
but i feel like
everything you've described about i i
love the tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick tick i love this i love
this after that i'm like i get me off
this [ __ ] thing like my head hurts
i'm like i i don't know it's too fast
the loop-de-loops everybody's screaming
i'm getting nauseous i don't know
there's something about even a bad even
a bad haunted house thing there's a
feeling to it that you're connected to
something bigger than yourself like
these carnies have been running this
[ __ ] scam on everybody for 150 years
and like it is just a shitty mass that
comes up with the light up but it's part
of something it's part of halloween it's
part of like just like i love the
cheapness of it i do love it where's
roller coasters i don't know well where
could you get the thrill of a roller
coaster in your life other than a roller
coaster it's a one-of-a-kind thing sure
okay and again i'm saying
the the variations you have there's
roller coasters that go from zero to 100
miles an hour and five three seconds
that's not fun that's not pleasant it is
that's pleasant there's ones that go
straight up and straight down sure
there's ones that go are looping there's
ones that loop backward there's ones
what about the way in which you lock in
there's one okay
when you're sitting and it's just a bar
this one's where you are you know you're
sitting and you're locked in from the
chest there's ones where you're just in
the chest and your feet are dangling
yeah i mean there's ones where you are
laying on your stomach so it feels like
you're flying okay but i will say that
largely haunted houses are are you and
your friend or you and your sweetheart
experience with roller coasters if you
don't get that front seat man like then
you're just staring at the back of
someone's head and that that's a harsh
thing man because that front seat to me
is the only good seat on the road
okay you can make the argument to the
front and the back but that still leaves
the vast majority of it is you're
crammed between people screaming in your
ear or you're looking at the back of
someone's head the entire time i like
that experience if you're in the dark
with your friend if you're with your
girl whatever you could grab hands she's
scared or he's scared whatever we want
to say like i like the the grabbing on
and stuff like that i don't know man
like it's a more
fun experience than just like let's just
blast you out
as fast as we can with a bunch of
strangers
there's no line for a haunted house
there's never a line from god damn pimp
yeah yeah well no but check this out we
are now we went to grand scale roller
coasters let me bring up the cyclone
cyclone the cyclone it's a rickety
wooden one yeah and a lot of the fear is
coming into uh not just the ups and
downs but will this fall apart or not
yes and it is
as
instilled in coney island and 100
carnival yeah you know
life as as a wanted house yeah it's it's
the end-all be the most famous roller
coaster in the world maybe yeah but i've
been on it three times in my life and i
don't need to go fourth cause it is not
a comfortable ride no i cannot go why to
coney island without getting on the
cycle get out of here what's the point
that's the number one thing i'm doing if
i go there i'm crossing it off the list
i'm getting some natives now going on
the slide nathan's i'm there with you
100 i'd rather do one of the freak shows
i'd rather spend my time doing something
that i couldn't the freak shows do
anywhere else you know what i mean
but not i'm not here to disrespect the
cyclone i love the cyclone i'm with it
it's the oldest wooden right wooden one
pimp just pulled this up and if you
thought cracker jacks was old at 1896
oh my god oh look i didn't even know it
was on june 16th 1884
oh that's before marty even went back in
time man holy [ __ ]
12 years before crackerjack was even a
yeah
a glimmer in someone's mind the first
roller coaster in america opened at
coney island wow known as switchbl
switchback railway it was the brainchild
of the marcus thompson traveled
approximately six miles an hour and
caught a nickel are they claiming that's
the cyclone well that's just a history
of roller coasters
oh okay maybe that's just well it was
that coney island i guess it became the
cyclone yeah
but i didn't realize that the first
roller coaster in the world came from
brooklyn came from coney island yeah
look ghost houses i think this is a good
point too like ghost houses do have a
lot of like
there's a technological good ones you
know what i mean they have the peppers
ghost where you see the illusion of the
ghost on the thing yeah um i don't know
man there's something to me if i had a
choice i'm just saying i like a haunted
house i like the story i like the
darkness i don't like it my age get my
head knocked around left and right i
don't like waiting online with kids i
hurt my neck yeah like where i heard it
yeah where i was like like it was you
know when you when you when you tweak it
for the whole like couple days yeah i
will say pimp go back to that i just
want to give a little history on the
haunted house because we haven't been
doing a lot of that one of the first
recorded purpose-built haunted
attractions
was the orton and spooner ghost house
which opened in 1915
in how would you pronounce that lip hook
lip hook what a great name
closely resembling a cardinal funhouse
it was powered by steam
yeah
i don't know man i think this is i i
couldn't tell you all right i think more
people all right i think more people are
going to like the roller coaster i agree
there are like there are people that
their goal is to go on every roller
coaster there's roller coaster like
clubs there's roller coaster stats
there's yeah i don't know i think roller
coasters are more ingrained in people
yeah i think they're wrong though
it's the same it's largely the same
experience over and over again okay okay
i feel all right pimp where we at
uh we're wait 15 minutes 5-0 let's go to
the phones all right all right this is
the rubber match the big tie breaker
feel free to read something
okay haunted house because i'm the exact
opposite of an adrenaline junkie and i'm
comfortable that the actors and haunted
houses aren't allowed to actually touch
you okay she took it in even another
direction from we were talking carny
ones but okay but also she's not an
adrenaline junkie my adrenaline gives me
a headache after a haunted house
yeah i guess i see but but
i don't know
yeah i guess
my girlfriend's service dog handles
haunted houses better than most
full-grown adults commenting on this
single-handedly set my choice because of
how cute it is
haunted house is just the unemployable
with face
why are they unemployed but they have
jobs not scary on a roller coaster you
might actually lose your life
i don't know if that's a plus or more
chances of me getting decapitated are
marginally less in a haunted house and
on a roller coaster so i'll go haunted
house
i'd rather piss my pants going in a
loop-de-loop and shut down the ride
rather than piss my pants and risk
someone's else slipping on it see now
here is not perfect are we saying their
names i know
i gotta go with roller coasters outside
of the haunted mansion at disney most
haunted houses are pretty hokey now
that is someone that's not getting it
right right the hokiness is for me part
of it i understood yeah the thing with
haunted houses is you have to find
something to make fun of or joke about
to enjoy it
if not you're scared shitless oh okay
that's positive positive yeah yeah uh
haunted house is a dog [ __ ]
worst holiday exclusive to ever be
created
who the [ __ ] willing likes to scare
themselves if i want to scare myself
i'll just look in the mirror what is up
dude is everything all right you're way
off based on that whenever people love
him
he has a strong stance if i want to [ __ ]
my pants may as well do it without
having a severe anxiety attack i know
for the most part i'm part i'm safe on a
roller coaster
in a haunted house no one's safe i will
start swinging me too i'd rather feel
like i'm gonna die in a haunted house
than no i could actually die on a roller
coaster i mean people are split yeah
people like split this could go either
way i can't fake being scared at a
haunted house and can't fake not being
scared
on a roller coaster but it's a lot less
awkward on the roller coaster whoa
here's a [ __ ] indictment of you
these aren't even comparable you two are
stretching now do they know we're not
allowed to
this is a very judgmental comment whoa
but then they answer it yeah roller
coasters are worth they are worth the
adrenaline but a haunted house is great
to watch someone literally [ __ ]
themselves so they had an opinion
yeah and they didn't make it clear which
one
yeah [ __ ] a haunted house i walk around
scandal until i'm already
ditto
yeah it seems pretty evenly evenly split
man i'm very curious about this i don't
think it's gonna be a blowout both make
me throw up and [ __ ] my pants but at
least the haunted house is easier to
collect myself
roller coaster all the way i'd rather
pee myself happy than scared guys this
is split i thought i thought roller
coaster was gonna take it
let's go to the phones we have over 8
000 votes
uh drum roll please pimpy throw out the
humble pie the stats
pimpus choosing roller coaster wow wow
well it wasn't indicative in the
comments no it was not indicative in the
comments nearly the same margin
as
cotton candy funnel cake we have roller
coaster at 71
and haunted house at 29
wow which means the rubber match i got
so i got you two to one on this one
today yeah you did you got this one i
mean jesus christ you know what though
it's like we said to darosa uh recently
the um the haunted house people are my
people
i got that and i'll just roll in with
them
that's what i'll lose exactly we just
covered ourselves with that both thrill
secrets yeah we're both real secrets
if i had to choose the thing is i'm i
don't want to go in a haunted house
because it's working now i guess like i
came here now i gotta go home and like
feel bad about myself for losing yeah i
don't know how you could go home now
actually you i think you're you're i
think sitting in that seat makes you
absorb derosa's quality yeah maybe
there's something to it
doesn't the stefano sit here too can i
grow three feet start speaking german i
i just don't do haunts i don't want to
be homeless you never like taunts i
don't like haunts i i like jaunts i see
cons you see i like haunted i like a
good haunt roller coaster is more of a
jaunt i wish that like i would see a
ghost or something like that it would
amazing yeah no one's ever seen one no
it's not be
yeah the haunted houses are still scary
they're [ __ ] fun man they're so much
fun i like that [ __ ] you remember the
one at sam lane did you ever go on that
one and that was an example of the worst
that was where i grew up on yeah that
was the one i was talking about that is
so lame oh it was bad you described it
exactly you go in there's a strobe
circle it it's just
the right operator and i would know
because i was one of them but i never
worked out line but i would see what
they do they would hit the button and
walk away they wouldn't even give a [ __ ]
because they knew you would be out of
there you'd be out in like 45 seconds it
was like flash
blast of air some strings and then a
goblin mask and you were done and the
horn right you're done
i was it was like 50 cents it was
[ __ ] i mean we grew up on this thing
yeah yeah my biggest regret was when
they uh closed that down and they
auctioned everything off we went down
remember yeah
and uh i got i was at the bar the night
before i got two dr i got two i was
hungover i didn't get there in time to
bid on one of the original skee-ball
machines
and that that thing was there from like
south beach rides staten island used to
be like coney island our boardwalk back
in the day it was a destination
thousands and thousands of people
vacation there yeah there was like there
was like rides on the board if you look
up old photos it was like a legit
destination yeah
um and the only remaining piece to that
was south beach rides yeah sand lane
amusement park and amusement park yeah
yeah i worked there two summers and uh
and that was there until we were well
into our like like 30s oh yeah oh was it
that late yeah yeah i was in my 30s i
was in i think right
like 30 yeah
because i started
that's the fun house that's what we're
talking about that's literally it that's
it pimpy that's it south beach rides fun
house
yeah those are
those those are the exact ones so they
there's seven of them i think they they
auction them off right there yeah and
i when i got there there was only two
left and i got nervous
and at the time i didn't have that but
one was up to 700 and something dollars
which isn't a lot
it's a piece of staten island history
and i got nervous and i didn't bid and
someone got it for seven something and
then then then it was the last one and i
was like f and i'm gonna do it but since
it was the last one
it went up to like like
over a thousand dollars like 1400 1600
and i shot myself on the floor i could
have had it with 700.
i i think about it to this day yeah you
should i have memories of me and you
going to that place like we used to go
there with the tickets remember
you're right you know what i think i was
like you know what i think i was it was
probably i was probably like just about
like 20 to 29. yeah it was yeah it
happened in like 2000 right around 2000
when did i it which probably closed down
2006. man i used to love that place they
used to have a pepsi day on wednesdays
where if you brought a pepsi can you got
it for half right so we would remember
they had no right for this but there was
two arcades across from it like there
was the haunted house all the rides and
then there was two like arcades so it
was two separate ticketing yes oh yeah a
separate prize one inside the park and
outside the park there was one that had
a raw bar
oh the clam bar the clam yeah yeah yeah
i never i i wouldn't that's not what i
ate when i was that age who's going in
there and getting raw people did man
their pizza was good they had the really
big slice
yeah oh dude i love that place man
anyway paige reminiscing yeah sounds
good um it ended in 99.
no no no that was the no yeah i thought
it was i was bartending
well well that might have been the
amusement park the the the
the what you're talking about the oh
just the just the yeah you're right
you're maybe right that close lately the
ride's closed but uh yeah the actual um
arcade
hung on a little bit that was it yeah
all right well there you have it uh well
thanks for listening to us go down
memory lane yeah if there's any staten
islanders listening yeah share a memory
of of the rides uh shout out salsa
windfall
salsa
the joe derosa's side project from 2007.
look it up online give it a couple extra
views what is that one rating he's got
there is that does anybody give uh
oh my god oh my god
2015.
joe got one rating
it's one star go ahead and read it this
is just shitty yuck this guy might be
the most inept comedian i've ever been
experiencing that's just that's just
that's why we know on a [ __ ] yeah
that's probably like uh on purpose oh
cause he's not inept he's very funny joe
oh yeah they're just they just give him
[ __ ] go comment on joe's old music and
let's try to get him to do a music video
oh my god
guys
go to salsa windfall right after you
finish watching this on youtube go
listen to it let's get his views up his
listens and
just how funny would it be if all of a
sudden all his salsa windfall songs had
like hundreds of comments i am telling
you right now that whenever we get back
on the road right the practicals always
get back on the road
if someone gets a salsa windfall tattoo
i am talking front row tickets front row
tickets
and and when was the last time i've ever
done a meet and greet
years i will not do them i i will i will
i will
they will show up with a song people
people our fans will get some windfall
tattoos
no but they will do it you're gonna end
up meeting like 100 people
i mean jesus christ man if i got to me
yeah
i gotta do it they have so many tattoos
of us it's not right yeah but a how's
the windfall one no no no but i'm saying
of us i always tell them don't do it
like they'll do like they'll do sign
your name and get that tattooed i'm like
you're gonna regret it you're going to
hate me i don't want to do it but then
there's people that get literally our
faces on them and there's people have
like you know how i have my jaidens yeah
if you guys don't know that i've jaden
tattooed on jaden smith tattooed on both
my thighs um like the realistic ones
they have some of those
wow someone got tattooed on them i'll
show you uh my meme yeah
wow oh really in in realistic realistic
oh my god yeah i saw this one the girl
has of me where it's like the rick where
the um where it's me and the headband
she i don't know why she picked this one
but it's
it's
it's huge it's from here to here on her
leg and and she's also like very pretty
so i'm like why would you put oh wow how
would you do that i know because because
that's something bad for her no matter
how much you love us you love the show
at some point that opinion is going to
shift i think you wouldn't like us
anymore but that you do not want that on
your s on your now did you guys see
drake's fan that got this oh my god
that's crazy
drake got mad at the tattoo artist drake
actually
put money if you go [ __ ] up this tattoo
it was crazy this is years ago now yeah
why did this woman do this you don't
remember this it was a huge thing no
also she she has no other discernible
tattoos why would she do it on her
forehead she was proud of it too far
ahead of his forehead i don't know
but actually to go back to derose's
music i think the punishment for having
the worst record should be he has to
open for you and only sing his music oh
come on i think we make i think we make
salsa we fall into something real i mean
he should that's an easy one we should
do that oh my god that's great i i i do
want to i i do want to the the girl who
has a tattoo with me on it i
i'm very flattered and thank you because
i don't want to make it oh i'm thankful
for all of you guys it's crazy
mind-blowing to me and my my response to
it is more about how i feel about myself
yes i feel bad that you did that because
i feel one day you'll will be mad at me
that i'm on your body yeah i don't feel
worthy to be on your body so i'm sorry
about that but it is a great tattoo yeah
yeah yeah yeah well um
uh oh we didn't do no matter what
happens i love you did we no but you can
end on that yeah
i love you too um and then you got uh
anything you want to just it's a
different episode it's the same thing
every every time i come back
these might be spread out and there
might be different people listening got
a podcast go tell them steve dave you
can find this everywhere around been
going for 11 years you'll you'll jump in
it's very intimidating to look at 500
plus episodes and uh and think you have
to you won't catch up but trust me we're
not doing anything you won't catch up on
sure it's more just knowing the
characters and so come on join on in i
told you i've said it before i love it
um and yeah i guess uh this will be in
somewhere in mid-january
i'm on tour guys savilecanoecomedy.com
everything's on sale we added second
shows
in foxwoods albany detroit pittsburgh
chicago
um
and uh madison i believe we added second
shows there so please check that out and
if i haven't been there yet los angeles
january 22nd at the wilton and uh in san
diego january 21st at the uh majestic
theater how long are you in l.a for uh i
gotta go in and come home because we're
you know i can't stay i wanted to to do
podcasts and [ __ ] but i can't
right yeah but uh thanks guys thanks for
listening and uh i still love you babe
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds